you know what I hate original films ah
who needs them more franchises I say we
just keep looking at sequels hey looper
one of my favorite YouTube channels has
this video they came out this month
upcoming movie sequels that will get you
hyped I really want to watch because
it's looper I think they're a great
channel and before we go into this and
speaking of sequels I wanted to mention
and if you follow us on our YouTube
community page you'll seen a post about
this our friends who I'm sure you've
heard of Jason and min and Ashley V
Robinson really big and the geek culture
community they wrote a comic book a
while ago it came out and I read the
whole thing in one sitting on a plane I
loved it it's called Jupiter jet you can
go to Amazon and you could you know
download it for your Kindle or buy a
physical copy like I got it's kind of
like a whole bunch of vibes like 1940s
50s Flair a little bit of like The
Rocketeer a little bit of like Indiana
Jones some more sci-fi mixes in there a
little bit of a Kim Possible flair as
well it's a great comic book for these
two who are major comic book nerds it
just shows and how well written and
executed and how wonderfully animated
the panels are as well they have a
sequel coming out called Jupiter jet in
the forgotten radio they have a
Kickstarter for right now if you have
read the first Jupiter Jed I'm sure you
loved it so go over to their Kickstarter
and show your support if you haven't
read Jupiter jet at all and you're
interested or you just want to show your
support to Jason and Ashley B Robinson
go over to their Kickstarter page there
are two links in the description box one
to get your copy of Jupiter jet Volume
one to to contribute to their
Kickstarter page this isn't like some
paid promotion they didn't ask us to
cover this in a YouTube video just
wanted to shout it out because I really
believe in this comic thank you guys
let's watch this
[Music]
these days movie fans are constantly
bombarded with trailers posters and new
information about all kinds of tentpole
franchise
yeah on the flip side however there are
a few upcoming movies that have managed
to I under the radar from a sci-fi epics
to action-packed thrillers here are some
of the sequels you might not know we're
being made I know about this oh yeah
works variety broke the news in August
20 19 but a new installment in the
series was indeed on the horizon and
that despite previous rumors it wouldn't
be following a new favorite movie
original stars Keanu Reeves and
carrie-anne moss will be returning for
the matrix for along with original
writer and director lana wachowski
Laurence Fishburne refuses them and
while Wachowski may have partnered with
her sister Lily to make the first three
Matrix movies the fourth installment
will have only the one wachowski at the
helm in addition to which how sweet the
script for the matrix war will be
co-written by Alexandre Helen and David
Mitchell and its deficit reduction in
early 2020 no plot details have yet been
revealed for the movie we won't even
understand coorporate moss or beads
characters who were killed in the third
film in the franchise The Matrix
Revolutions it is equally unclear
whether Laurence Fishburne's character
Morpheus will be making an appearance
shop and the main credits may be recast
in order to appear as a younger version
of the character but that remains
speculation for now James Cameron has
been talking about almost from the
moment the first filming ceremony the
rest of the ten minutes of this video
eventually becoming the highest-grossing
film of all time
however despite years of Cameron's
repeated promises of a vast and
expensive avatar franchise it was
beginning to feel as though a follow up
was as far off and unreachable as the
moon of pantora itself still believe it
or not firm or avatars really do appear
to be imminent
in fact according to Sigourney Weaver
the first two have already finished
shooting they've even got white avatar
the way of water
first you are done shooting [ __ ] the
quest for a WA what does it all mean
I had no idea one knows except James
Cameron himself and his eclectic cast
which in addition to the original movie
stars also features a host of newcomers
including Edie Falco Kate Winslet's
Michelle Yeoh Jemaine Clement and Vin
Diesel we'll have to wait and shermaine
is the one I'm most excited about water
is scheduled for release on December
17th 2021 first accede bearer arriving
on December 22nd 2023 Natasha Tolkien
writer following on December 19th 2025
the second quest for a WA concluding the
franchise on December 17th that's been
canceled Roma learned the hard way all
the way to another right it's pretty
hard to kill an alien and the Alien
franchise seems just as tough as the
creature is just one about his wind or
sci-fi horror film on its 40th
anniversary mr. Ridley Scott told
variety that a third prequel is indeed
on the way intended as a follow-up to
2012 prometheus and 2017 alien covenant
despite generally positive critical
reviews covenant underperformed at the
box office
throwing the future of the franchise in
uncertainty but following Disney's
acquisition of Fox both Scott and aliens
new studio homes seemed eager to return
to the sinister stars yet again as for
what this third prequel might be about
only one thing is for sure it won't
follow the format of the original alien
speaking to The Hollywood Reporter Scott
talked about the need for the franchise
to continue to evolve in order to
succeed he said you can't keep repeating
the same premise because the joke gets
boring
the next alien shown in the very early
stages and none of the cast of Covenant
has
yep and asked to return still Scott
maintains three things it's happening
he'll be directing it and it's currently
in a script phase after the release of
the poorly received Indiana Jones and
the Kingdom of the Crystal Skull no one
would have blamed Harrison Ford Steven
Spielberg and everyone else at Lucasfilm
if they'd given up on the Indiana Jones
franchise together the banquet appears
that Indy will be back with Indiana
Jones 5 which despite a number of push
backs and delays is still theoretically
happening
Indiana Jones 5 has gone through a
number of screenwriters already from
Crystal Skull scribe David Koepp two
solos Jonathan Kasdan - this is us
create very pronounced an income now
apparently back to kept saying don't
have all these here's what Indiana Jones
5 will be about although Harrison Ford
would be at least 78 when the movie
starts filming about the beginning of
the talking physically rigorous than
previous installments chillest anemia of
course it's possible that even the
filmmakers don't quite know the movie's
plot yet speaking to den of geek in
September of 2019 kept said I'm working
on it again we're still trying and I
think we've got a good idea this time
we'll see if Indiana Jones flies around
in the good idea stage it's probably got
a long way to go before it actually hits
theaters still according to everyone
involved it'll get there eventually
we'll may have finally been killed at
the end of 2009
director Quentin Tarantino from
expressing his desire for an others put
the Vega brothers on here then if you
want that the third kill bill would
focus on the daughter of Vernita green
yes Ana forever own up and on the hunt
for revenge against the person who
killed her mother don't have miss
Beatrix I wanted has said that he's had
talks with Thurman about Kill Bill Vol 3
as recently as July of 2019 telling MTV
if any of my movies were going to spring
for my other movies it would be a third
kill bill of course a third kill bill
may throw a wrench in Tarantino's plans
to retire after his tenth film his ninth
Once Upon a Time in Hollywood hit
theaters in the summer of 2019
and his 10th an upcoming Star Trek film
is currently in the works cancelled yes
too old to keep going nothing is
finalized for it oh they'll sequel again
but it seems as though all that would be
reeded for it to materialize is simply
for tarantino to decide to pull the
trigger
although rumor has it that a third
Sherlock Holmes film has always been
part of the plan over a Warner well what
the Hypnose billionaire playboy
philanthropist Tony Stark saving the
world are you sure you're ready
beautifully a pretty draining gig and
Tony's superhero commitments kept him
from being able to take up Sherlock's
trademark deerstalker and hype for a
third time but now that downey really
exited the MCU for good he finally has
the time to team up with watson solve
one more case and take his last bow as
the famous detective
the third Sherlock Holmes film will be
hummed by Rocket Man director Dexter
Fletcher a departure from the throne oh
yeah that's right well Sherlock Holmes
three was originally scheduled to
release on Christmas Day 2020 it has
since been pushed back a year and will
now be starting in two feeders in
December 2021 the hit man's bodyguard
wasn't exactly what yeah there's a
seagull but the movie did pretty well at
the box office
pulling in almost 177 million dollars
worldwide against a 30 million dollar
budget after all how can an audience
possibly say no to the combined charisma
of Ryan Reynolds and samuel l.jackson
well fans of the first film will be
happy to know that the hit man's
bodyguard is getting a sequel
confusingly titled the hit man's wife's
bodyguard Reynolds and China are both
returning and Salma Hayek is also coming
back as the titular wife according to
The Hollywood Reporter the plot will
find Reynolds bodyguards trying to live
a peaceful life when he gets mixed up
with Jackson's hit man once more
along with Hayek the trio will
apparently wreak havoc along the Amalfi
Coast and an attempted summer I doesn't
die in the first the movie will also
start
like Morgan Freeman Antonio Banderas
Frank Grillo and Richard e-grants it has
been for a while time at the movie is
special one for you insiders are
describing this film as the good the bad
and the bat-crazy according to Deadline
Robocop is indeed returning Robocop
return although it seems this new film
is going to mess around with the
franchise's continuity the original
Robocop was directed by Paul beare joven
and it made quite a killing when it was
released in 1985 after two sequels story
original order Peter Weller the
franchise was rebooted in 2014 with
actor Joel Kinnaman and director Jose
Peggy Lee I thought the remake wasn't
nearly as popular as the first film
sadly for mr. Kinnaman it looks like the
new movie is going to ignore the recent
remake altogether the latest century in
the frame is that Bob local cop returned
I forgot he played him back the guys who
penned the first film in fact the
Robocop Returns was apparently written
right after the original was released
sadly never really but now MGM is yet
another go with the help of some
rewrites by Terminator dark fate writer
Justin Rhodes yes to reprise his Robo
role as for the plot synopsis deadline
breaks in archaea brains and the fate of
Detroit hangs in the balance as Robocop
makes his triumphant return to fight
crime and corruption though district
names Neill Blomkamp was initially
attached to direct he announced in
August 2019 that scheduling conflicts
had forced him to depart the project you
know those three too many short films
mobsters director aid Forsyth had taken
up the helm of Robocop retail and would
also be giving the screenplay a fresh
rewrite your move creep why update the
screenplay yeah what do you reckon to
the hungry zombies with a very fast
train and vertically acclaimed
blockbuster that desperately needs a
sequel apparently released in 2016 train
to Busan Earth South Korea and wowed
critics across the globe okay this plot
follows a selfish businessman who's
taking his daughter on a train ride to
the city of Busan when zombies suddenly
start popping up all over the place at
first the protagonist is only
served with protecting himself and his
kid but as things get bloodier and
bloodier the other passengers escape the
oncoming horde now it seems writer
director Jung sang ho is working on
ports you supposedly titled abandoned
Sodor net so they just last half-hour
across Korea shooting began in the
summer oh no the camera it's evidently a
good time to be in the zombie train
business as new line is currently
working on an American remake of the
first film Thank You Naaman on you can
watch some titles at one-inch barrier
subtitlers glory over on Netflix
Sylvester Stallone and the Expendables 4
have been injured time will they won't
they dance for a few years now but the
latest sign seemed to point definitively
to they will taking to his own Instagram
account still owned announced in july
2019 that the sequel was back on with a
photo of the star and his Expendables
gear and the caption all of those July
4th fireworks got my mind going I'm
starting to cook up the next adventure
still on directed co-wrote and then July
5th rolled right never mind right the
existing two sequels although for those
he handed off directorial duties to
Simon West for two and Patrick Hughes
for three he walked away from the
Expendables war back in 2017 but his
exit appears to have been only temporary
in addition always is when Stallone has
been a veritable who's who of current
and former action superstars but only
Jason Statham and Arnold Schwarzenegger
have been confirmed as joining Stallone
in the Expendables 4
and once the loan does finalize the
fourth installment in the series though
you can expect the cast list to grow
exponentially
we've been even more impressed to
respect Gibson and Van Damme yeah after
the run away stood an integer books and
films audiences would one day that's
prequel the dystopian world of Panem way
or another and sure enough in June 2019
publisher scholastic announced that it
would be releasing another novel by
Suzanne Collins sent in The Hunger Games
world this book would be a prequel set
64 years before the events of the
original story and would focus on the
10th Hunger Games in October 29th see
that's the one I wanna know what's
revealed The Ballad of songbirds and
snakes along with the announcement of
the novel came to confirmation that
Collins prequel will also receive the
movie treatment Lionsgate chairman Joe
Drake who studio adapted the Hunger
Games films said of the book
announcement as the proud home of The
Hunger Games Movies we can hardly wait
for Suzanne's next book to be published
we think we told her to write our during
the writing process and we look forward
to continuing to work closely with her
on the movie The Ballad of songbirds and
snakes is scheduled to hit bookshelves
on May 19th
maybe we'll see her parents they were
nobody
when they were babies directed by the
one and only John Carpenter bigtrip
waters China is one of the wackiest
action movies ever made they were
rebuilding this or soft reboot in the
dark and magical underbelly of San
Francisco's Chinatown with its Mortal
Kombat style warriors and magical sword
fights Big Trouble in Little China has
become a beloved classic so naturally
well we're a bit worried when a remake
with Dwayne Johnson was announced in
2015 there hasn't been a lot of new info
since then but it's now clear that the
new big trouble will actually be a
sequel speaking decline it'll be like a
Jumanji to have a seat
so what we're planning to do is continue
the story we're going to continue the
universe of the university I went on to
explain the events of the first film
will still exist in the new Dwayne
Johnson movie on top of that the rock
will be playing a new character rather
than Jeff Burton it'll probably still be
called
Big Trouble in Little Rock and a
pre-established timeline but also serves
as a kind of reboot for a new generation
unfortunately her Russell has told us a
today that he probably won't be in the
sequel
so Burton himsel quit early won't be
back in the action for this one nobody
messes with the Jesus oh this trailer
were supposed to have come out after all
tuturro played the purple clad Jesus and
The Big Lebowski and even though he's
only on screen for two scenes the pervy
Boulder apparently made enough of an
impression to warn his own spin-off
movie it's called going places it's now
known as the Jesus rolls and it has
absolutely nothing to do with the dude
yeah well you know just like
your opinion man who's just been
released from jail after he was framed
for a crime he didn't commit now a free
man he teams up with two friends and
goes on a wild road trip according to
the film's official plot synopsis the
movie is a film about a trio of misfits
whose irreverent sexually charged
dynamic evolves into a surprising love
story their spontaneous and flippant
attitude towards the past or future
backfires time and again even as they
inadvertently perform good deeds in
September 2008 a trailer for the Jesus
rolls appeared there was a trailer as
for the dynamic directing duo the Cohens
aren't involved with this spin-off
sequel but they're still totally cool
with - Turo making a part - almost two
decades after the first baseman's
animation and professional basketball
Warner Brothers announced in early 2014
Michael a follow up to the 1996 film the
original Space Jam starred NBA superstar
Michael Jordan and featured appearances
from a number of other NBA players
alongside its animated cast the sequel
will star NBA MVP LeBron James in
addition to dawn she's almost deaf you
could be anything never know Marvel
Cinematic Universe with the production
team that includes Black Panthers Ryan
Coogler and The Fast and the Furious
series Justin Lin Space Jam 2 will be
harmed by director Malcolm D Lee Lee
wasn't the first director attached to
the film though he stepped in for
Terrence Nance who departed the
production on good terms and july 2019
citing creative differences the film is
set to hit theaters on July 16 2021
almost a full quarter of a century after
the first cool good less - I'm so hyped
right now all right well I'm interested
in about two-thirds of this the matrix
four is something I'm very much excited
for and what I did there
we call that a homophone right um who
are they spelled the same and sound the
same or they spelled different spell
different okay so it's a homophone dude
that's my contribution I feel like when
we see the trailer it's not gonna be
something that really tells us what the
movies about we're gonna always your
plot details are kept under wraps but
it's the matrix most people didn't
understand the first movie when it came
out and it was a global box office smash
reloaded came out same thing no one
understood the last 20 minutes of that
movie or a lot of it for that matter the
Matrix movies that her trailers don't
really tell you what the film's about
but I'm excited for is Yaya Abdul Mateen
and yeah is in the film and he is
someone who I think can be a superstar
if you please you can either go down the
Sam Worthington path or you I think he's
gonna be really famous but isn't but I
think he's got a good shot with Aquaman
Watchmen is that episode of Black Mirror
now this this dude is everywhere the
pop-culture zeitgeist but I'm really
excited for it I'm really happy with the
fact that lana wachowski obviously
coming to return but the fact that the
screenwriters other people putting input
in the screenplay
as opposed to just letting it be bought
on her sister writing in a kind of
bummer sister's not coming back for it
because it felt like it was a sibling
duo a good that's what made those films
so so special now it'll be directed by a
wachowski mystery which has said goodbye
of Wachowskis sister yes i mean people
have been speculating how neo and
Trinity can come back in the matrix for
with carrie anne moss counters returning
The Matrix Reloaded they established
that there are programs Trinity program
and the
program so I fear they can come back
within the matrix not in the real world
of a scion in a weird way I can see why
we're not hearing about Laurence
Fishburne returning but we're hearing
about neo and Trinity able to appear in
this movie but they'll play an integral
role but I don't think they'll be the
stars there's got to be a new generation
you have people in pass the baton love
avatar when we hear there's a trailer
coming out for the second one I'm gonna
re-watch the first movie because I only
saw the one time in theaters and I want
to see if I'm gonna be excited for
another Avatar movie it seems to be like
the most popular movie of all time that
no one really cares just the impression
I'm getting nobody ever brings it up you
know what they keep bringing up is it
seems like Tiant if initially delayed
sequels of avatar well that's it's
become one of those franchises where I
will believe it when I see it
ya know and until there is a movie in
the theaters I'm not gonna fully believe
it and I'm not sure I'll believe all the
sequel see Ridley Scott's talking about
alien awakening saying you can't repeat
yourself I wish he applied that advice
for covenant whatever I think it's gonna
flop I think I don't think early Scott I
thought might be there were some tense
sequences and covenant that I really did
enjoy an overall enjoyed the movie but I
have in Calgary watcher not keeping the
greatness of alien that ever known loves
alive I really think Tarantino should do
Kill Bill Vol three I don't think it's
gonna happen but I really think he
should and I've said it a bunch of times
that I would be cool with it being his
10th film and what's the point of time
in Hollywood already felt like a strange
culmination that borrowed bits and
pieces of other works of Tarantino and
the one thing we haven't seen him do is
an official sequel to one of his films
volume 1 and volume 2 in his mind and
depending on which film fan you're
talking to considers that one whole
movie they don't consider volume 2 a
sequel he could go out with a bang or a
slice
yeah yeah yeah spatter of blood yes if
he was able to put like the first
official sequel from Tarantino and he
does a great job with it I think that
would be really cool I would love to see
a volume I just don't think it's gonna
happen one of all the things on this
list I feel like that would get people
the most hyped if it were to happen yeah
cuz that movie has such a legacy now I
was excited for Robocop Returns when I
heard Neill Blomkamp was doing it and it
just seems like something that's right
in his wheelhouse I didn't know that
this screenplay
that they are working off of and
rewriting is the original sequel script
to Robocop
where's nostalgia which is pretty cool
and I don't really know that many
situations of that happening I've heard
of a lot of original spec scripts that
are sitting on the shelf or took like
you know it's a couple of decades to get
this script off the ground but not with
a sequel where they go let's go back to
the original sequel script and adapt
that that to me sounds really cool but
it's Robocop and I feel like without
Paul Verhoeven
behind it Weller yeah it's just can't
know the script
it'll be the true sequel Robocop yeah
and then we can call Robocop 2 but this
time it's the real Robocop - unless it's
bad and then it's not the hit man's
wife's body garden awesome
Expendables 4 awesome whenever Stallone
says he's retiring a character or
franchise don't believe him never
believe him it's a good thing we don't
believe him because we're always excited
when he returns anyways it's not like
come on put up the Jersey he has to fake
us out so that when he starts to come
back we get that much more exciting
sadly and it works being Trouble in
Little China - which I feel like will
undoubtedly be called one of the soft
reboot titles if not the exact same
title like bigger the big trouble yeah
Big Trouble in Little China the troubles
in some weird one word add on or a
plural - one of those words either way I
don't see the point I feel like it would
flop oh you know it's like a trailer can
do wonders for you so if it happens to
have like this insanely cool appealing
trailer I feel like that could get
people hooked I don't feel like the
nostalgia or fan base for a Dwayne
Johnson led vehicle reboot for big
trouble yeah like I just don't see the
correlation of that hooking one another
in however I could see them kind of
doing what they did with Jumanji welcome
to the jungle where it's technically a
continuation it's technically a sequel
but it really is its own thing because
Big Trouble in Little China is such a
product of its time really at john
carpenter's use of like asian culture
then was riffing on the kind of ways we
use asian culture and movies at that
time yeah you can't do that today i just
don't know how old well yeah the
sensibility would have to be really like
i can see you doing a continuation if
they live but like big trouble seems
like you've said such a product of its
time that i'm not sure how you would
transcribe it to today's stand like the
sensibilities sherlock holmes 3 I'm
excited for that
I've been wanting a part 3 for a while I
gonna really enjoy the comedy in those
films I really enjoy the action I think
any of them are as clever or witty or
intelligent has other Sherlock Holmes
that have tasted the quintessential
Holmes Arthur Conan Doyle had in mind
but in terms of like big blockbuster
Sherlock Holmes movies and then getting
the director from Rock a man to do this
that sounds pretty neat to me and I be
down to watch that and I feel like
Dexter Fletcher can bring a certain
personality and flirted with that would
distinguish itself from the Guy Ritchie
style and also I think Robert Downey jr.
does need another movie two little loops
yeah I mean he could do something
original - doesn't often I'll be
franchises but I think sometimes you
know for an actor whose careers
something like this you know it's like
it's a good middle ground get people
hyped up to see him pick back up he's
not playing Iron Man again but he's
still doing it
Jesus roles I don't know who this movies
for I mean I feel like it could be good
like it's one of those that
seems like such an odd idea and it
almost reminds me of like a better call
Saul scenario like where maybe this
movie's gonna feel markedly different
from the Big Lebowski but of the same
world but also yeah I'm not sure who
it's for other than like Lebowski
diehards and people who just love yeah
alright guys well what sequel are you
most excited for leave a comment down
below please subscribe to looper you
could subscribe to us loop your way to
that notification Mel and then you know
zigzag over to that like button this is
going well hey and I like to end this
with a patron today shout out to a
lovely woman named Erica Tuesday take it
away John Erica you know i'm hype for
i'm hyped for your eventual sequel to an
animated movie that you wrote directed
drew and starred in yourself I want to
see you on a looper list and I want to
argue about the validity of the spot
that you got on the list cuz I think you
should be higher Greg thinks you
shouldn't be on the list at all and I'm
telling him he's an idiot because you
are one of the most talented people I
know so take care and you know let's go
see some avatar sequels together in ten
years very good thanks Greg I've been
studying